look out j-lo a-rod's coming for your
moves
okay so jennifer lopez is still the
reigning queen of dance
thank you but her fiance alex rodriguez
is trying his best to keep
up having a blast the former baseball
pro and his 15 year old daughter natasha
celebrated the los
angeles dodgers win over the braves on
sunday with a little tick-tock action
taking on jennifer's choreography from
the music video to her hit
potty
[Music]
the former yankee player captioned the
clip quote this is how excited i am
about game seven
how'd i do j-lo i love it well a-rod's
leading lady had
nothing but praise for her man hitting
up the comments to say
quote i love when you dance
you know what i love when he dances too
mainly because he has one
seriously epic dance face like that's
the look of a man who is taking his
choreo seriously
and i respect that thank you guys fun
fact
natasha actually makes a brief cameo in
the potty music video that debuted on
tick tock
last month
[Music]
yeah that right there that's a rod's
baby girl
how proud are you very very proud back
in september
alex instagramed this shot with natasha
on the set of the music video
gushing over jen in the caption quote so
proud of her for working so hard and
creating another amazing hit
can't stop listening to it plus i hear
there's even a surprise guest in the
video
but back to those moves
this isn't the first time we've seen the
45 year old try to keep up with jenny
from the block
[Music]
back in july j lo tick-tocked her booty
off with the help of alex
his 12 year old daughter ella her 12
year old daughter emmy and chicago white
sox player nick silva
dancing to a ton of hits from the early
2000s
again please note the intense dance face
and who could forget back in march when
a-rod danced around in his ladies dress
for the whole internet to see what can i
tell you
alex took on the flip the switch
challenge and let me warn you
you can't unsee it
i mean those two really are tick-tock
couple goals
i mean my life right now is just so
amazing
uh my personal life you know my kids
everything everything's just in a great
place and i feel
really lucky and hey alex keep on
serving up those
moves we are here for it we've seen her
trying to teach you how to dance could
you get up there and do a
[Laughter]
that is a lifelong journey that will
never land
but you know i just keep trying i get a
c for effort